father Smith family - a dad how long
have you all been eating poop
we have never eaten poop Herrmann my
neighbor Smith family I'm dr. Wong come
on in I was told there was a grandpa
that might be joining us he got wrapped
up in an experiment he's a scientist
like legit like on an intergalactic
sci-fi level his work is very turned
himself into a pic or D mom's talking
I'm sorry I suppose that's a good segue
into our little discipline cases here
does Grandpa turn himself into a pickle
a lot why so what kind of question is
that the kind that wasn't designed to
attack or hurt you in any way
oh Jesus Christ one of these no my
father has never turned himself into a
pickle before he's unpredictable and
eccentric the whole family is speaking
of which okay let's open things up to
the whole family and let me ask this why
do we think grandpa turned himself into
a pickle
everybody knew pickle rig let's break
this down and there is a new round of
the merch giveaway all you have to do to
enter just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so if you never
thought that you'd have to learn the
word corporal Faiza means what you think
it means just a compulsion to eat poop
it's mostly used in reference to dogs
it's actually a pretty serious thing but
people actually suffer from it - in real
life so all of a sudden you'll go back
and re-watch seasons 1 and 2 and you
won't look at mr. goldenfold the same
way twice or I'm sure there's a crackpot
theory in there somewhere that Rick and
Morty caused this in him when they went
into his mind during the scary Terry
episode where they were trying to change
Morty's grades so he could come on
adventures with Rick that's one of the
best things about Rick and Morty is the
way they recontextualize characters with
big shocking details later on although
the episode where they went into his
mind he was pretty badass in that dream
to begin with so he probably has way
more messed-up stuff going on but this
family therapy session if you couldn't
tell the voice of dr. Wong is Susan
Sarandon she has a pretty identifiable
voice but outside of their send-up of
some of the tropes of traditional family
therapy if you've ever had to sit
through therapy session with the family
it's already
maduk to begin with but as is this case
rick has already turned himself into a
pickle so you've already had these
scenes you already had this adventure
where he might be stuck down the drain
Morty's reaction is fairly consistent
with episode 1 where he's had enough of
Rick's [ __ ] but Beth and summer still
kind of idolized him Beth is the funny
one in this scene this is probably more
of a bad scene than anything else
because you start to learn more about
her childhood this year and you can see
how she idolizes Rick because he was
always gone so she talks about how he's
a scientist like it's this amazing thing
oh you wouldn't understand he's doing
very important stuff and I loved all the
while susan sarandon characters just
sitting there taking it all in like why
do you think he turned himself into a
pickle cue massive I role I'll link the
other trailer video at the end of this
but you get that line from brick where
he tells Morty stop looking for layers I
turned myself into a pickle it's just
meant to be awesome so obviously that's
a meta commentary for the audience like
Dan Harmon and the writers just sort of
poking fun at all the fan series that
people come up with but it's also
commentary on this therapy session too
don't look for hidden layers Rick turned
himself into a pickle we're going
through a divorce we're trying to deal
with it so in addition to all the crazy
pickle stuff that's going on which is
going to be awesome they're also making
fun of therapy in general not just with
this scene but with a lot of Rick's
ideas in the episode regardless of what
you think of episode so far this season
which I think it's been a really awesome
season I feel like they've done a much
better job of tying the ideas of the
episode to the actual plot of the
episode so like that goes as this Grand
Thunderdome adventure is a way to avoid
their real life like we don't want to
deal with the divorce summer tells Rick
is there an adventure that you want to
be to go on anywhere it can be anything
anything to get me out of this garage
with my father right now
so the tickle Rick episode is sort of an
exploration of what's going on at Beth's
head in the idea that just not to over
complicate matters like don't push for
hidden meaning and what's going on in
each of these people's heads while this
divorce is playing out this season if
you think all the stuff at the beginning
with mr. goldenfold was funny they
actually improved an episode last year
where they did the same thing so maybe
they just have it on their mind but it's
funny how that worked its way back into
an episode faint in interior Morty's
garage
Rick is working at his workbench on some
punted contraption summer enters brick I
don't know if I you can go I want to
apply to MIT but then I was also
thinking about maybe applying to Yale do
you think
which one's the summer summer summer
listen that's all really good but me and
Morty are working on a device where I
can inject a hundred and twenty cc's of
BC's into his knees okay okay okay all
right right but like I really need to
figure out what it is that I'm going to
do with the on Rick help summer out I
mean I know I want to cut my legs off
with the 120 cc's of feces and all but
like Morty you've been begging me for
weeks to figure out a way to decapitate
your leg reveal that Morty is laying on
the floor in the fetal position his
knees bent legs are swollen with with
septic shock oh my god Rick give him
some antibiotics no it's okay summer I'm
doing alright he numbed them all up real
good I just you know Rick you really
should point was in the summer she's
cute she's got some serious questions
about educational things yeah yeah I
mean do i major in in in physics or or
arts or I think you might want to major
in sharing a [ __ ] up summer coming to
Harvard
that's the Dean of Admissions sits
behind his desk or the Dean of a mission
Oh interesting hi oh hello so thank you
so much for seeing me as meeting my my
grandfather Rick loves everything you've
done with those facilities and if you
know don't worry about the threats see
your physical body it's going to be fine
as long as I get I got accepted one
question yeah how did you feel about
beating and their introduction to me so
we'll see how much more this trailer
footage actually shows up in the episode
the trailer is I think only from the
first couple of episodes they only have
up to seven listed on the wiki in terms
of titles but the next episode 4 is
Vindicator 3 the return of the world
Endor that might be what this footage in
the trailer is it sort of looks like a
send-up on guardians of the galaxy on
the outset but in the way that pickle
rick is sort of dealing with the
emotional consequences of the divorce
we'll see what episode force like real
big through line is so let me know in
the comments what do you guys think of
the way they've done that this season
where it's a little more serial eyes but
it's really just one aspect of the show
that's become more heavily serialized
but what's going to happen is I'll post
my episode video Monday morning just
like I normally would if they drop more
footage I'll do another video for it but
I know there's a whole bunch of stuff
going around with the Game of Thrones
leak so please don't post spoilers for
that in the comments especially because
this is a Rick and Morty video anyway
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Kevin and B please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you win the Zen monkey studios
merch this week while you wait for
everything you can click here for more
pickle Rick footage and you can click
here for brand new Game of Thrones thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you
[Applause]